notre émission spéciale continue centrée
autour du Nouvel Ordre Mondial les
questions posées depuis des mois avec
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
trouve un écho on a commencé de
l'évoquer évident au Proche Orient
beaucoup de questions à aborder on parle
d'une guerre mondialisée depuis le début
de de de l'invasion de l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'elle vient d'ouvrir un nouveau front
quel pays pourrait servir de médiateur
pourquoi l'Occident n'a plus la clé quel
rôle la Chine pourrait éventuellement
jouer dans les prochaines semaines avant
de répondre on voit ce que change le
conflit israélo-palestinien dans sa
dernière dans ses dernières semaines
avec
redaambit les attaques du Hamas changent
la donne d'un point de vue géopolitique
notamment au Moyen-Orient c'est remettre
la question de la Palestine à l'agenda
en montrant que on peut pas contourner
les acteurs Palestiniens notamment en
faisant une série de normalisations avec
les les acteurs arabes par exemple
l'Arabie Saoudite et c'est espéré une
escalade dans la région avec un S Stien
de l'Iran notamment via le hzbollah
l'Iran dans le viseur d'Israël et de ses
alliés
américains nous apportons déjà une aide
militaire supplémentaire aux forces de
défense israélienne notamment des
munitions et nous avons signaler
clairement aux Iraniens faites attention
les États-Unis acteurs majeurs dans le
soutien militaire de ses partenaires le
retour au premier plan du conflit
israélopalestinien peut-il empêcher
l'Amérique d'être sur tous les fronts et
surtout le conflit ukrainien va-t-il
passer en arrière-plan à ces deux
questions volodimir Zelinski a obtenu
une
réponse il a été clairement exprimé que
l'Amérique continuera à fournir à
l'Ukraine le soutien constant et
ininterrompu nécessaire à sa
défense la Russie elle espère pourtant
un affaiblissement militaire de
l'Ukraine et en profite pour pointer du
doigt la diplomatie américaine sepposant
comme un potentiel médiateur entre
Israël et la PAL
malheureusement nous constatons une
brusque aggravation de la situation au
Moyen-Orient je pense que beaucoup de
gens seraient d'accord avec moi pour
dire que c'est un exemple clair de
l'échec de la politique américaine au
Moyen-Orient d'autres acteurs du
Moyen-Orient pourrai jouer ce rôle
d'intermédiaire est-ce que du coup ça va
être l'occasion pour l'Arabie Saoudite
qui avait déjà proposé un plan de Pai en
2002 de reprendre l'initiative et
d'essayer finalement de proposer quelque
chose en raison de des relations avec
Israël maintenant mais en en en exigeant
et en obtenant des vraies garanties pour
les Palestiniens est-ce que ça c'est une
nouvelle ère qui peut s'ouvrir d'un
point de vue diplomatique on peut rêver
un Occident et une Amérique
potentiellement en retrait des pays
voisins qui veulent jouer un rôle et
d'autres conflits à prendre en compte un
nouvel ordre mondial pourrait bien
émerger dans les prochaines semaines
voilà c'est évidemment difficile de
s'extirper de l'émotion provoqué par par
les images et les massacres dont on
parle depuis depuis 6 jours mais on va
essayer de le faire dans ce débat et
c'est l'objectif et c'est je pense la
mission de notre notre sens public
François isbourg bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes conseiller à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique auteur de ce livre
les leçons d'une guerre aux éditionil
Jacob vous y analysez les conséquences
du de la guerre en Ukraine de l'invasion
de l'Ukraine par la Russie syv Berman
bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi ancienne
ambassadrice de France vous publiez
madame l'ambassadeur de à Moscou une vie
de diplomate c'est aux édition Talandier
Damien Simonon bonsoir et bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes maître de
conférence en sciences politique à
linalcoinstitut national des langues et
civilisations orientales etmil ce qui
est resté évidemment à mes côtés
éctoraliste pour sens public alors je
vais reprendre cette expression de
guerre mondialisée je sais pas si vous
le si vous l'acceptez françoisbour mais
est-ce que c'est un nouveau front qui
vient de s'ouvrir dans ce qu'on appelle
dans ce qu'on appelle depuis 18 ou 19
mois la guerre mondialisée je pense que
la et Israël récuseraiit cette
expression il y a une guerre entre
Israël et le et le ramas je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit une une guerre
mondialisée elle pourrait le devenirin
si l'Iran et les Hezbollah entrent dans
la danse si les États-Unis ripostent
contre
l'Iran ou que sais-je mais à l'heure
actuelle on a bien à faire à un autre
conflit par rapport auquel il y a des
bénéfices
géopolitique il y a des perdants
géopolitiques mais ça n'en fait pas un
conflit mondialisé à ce stade Sylvie
Berman quand quand quand vous quand on
évoque ce nouvel ordre mondial c'est
sont des débats qu'on a déjà eu ici
ensemble on a un peu le sentiment que
les pays occidentaux ont perdu la clé
est-ce que c'est aussi votre sentiment
depuis une semaine dans ce conflit au
proch rien alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ce qui concerne la guerre en
Ukraine et la position justement des
pays du Sud beaucoup disaient c'est une
guerre européenne euh et vous voulez
qu'on s'y intéresse quand ça se passe
dans notre région comme en Palestine ça
ne vous intéresse pas donc effectivement
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a eu un
désintérêt mais pas seulement des
Occidentaux des pays arabes qui
n'avaient absolument rien à faire euh du
peuple palestinien et des dirigeants en
tout cas euh mais aujourd'hui du coup le
l'Occident finalement est relativement
impuissant mais l'Occident a été frappé
dans son ensemble d'une certaine manière
puisqu'il y a eu des otages de beaucoup
de de pays occidentaux moi ce que je
pense c'est qu'il faudra un jour bon ça
était un conflit c'est ce que j'avais
écrit c'est le retour du du refoulé si
on ne veut pas que ça recommence je
crois que il faudra se réinvestir dans
ce qu'on appelle le processus de paix
même si effectivement les pays de la
région maintenant TI a joué un rôle ouis
c'est certainement impossible à entendre
pour les familles de de victimes d'Amien
Simono mais est-ce qu'on peut dire que
les attaques terroristes du les
massacres commis par le Hamas vont
obliger la communauté internationale à
remettre cette question du processus de
paix finalement sur les rails ben en
fait moi ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est
moi j'étais en Israël dans le territoire
palestinien cet été et tout le monde
parlait des accords d'Abraham tout le
monde parlait enfin du moins du côté
palestinien du côté israélien pardon des
acccords d'Abraham alors on va redire
même si nos téléspectateurs sont voilà
on en a beaucoup parlé 2020 un
rapprochement entre Israël et plusieurs
pays le Maroc émirats Arab Unis Bahrain
le Soudan également lesir le Bahrain
exactementarab et en effet notamment le
projet des routes de la soie également
qui a été discuté en Inde il y a
maintenant un mois mettait en relation
Israël les pays du Golf certains pays du
golf et l'Arabie Saoudite donc c'était
en effet de C dont on parle cette
attaque du Hamas elle vient remettre la
question palestinienne au centre du jeu
il semblerait en effet que nos
diplomaties occidentale notamment
française se contentaiit de voilà de
communiquer à chaque fois qu'il y avait
des violences de part et d'autrre là ça
replace véritablement le fait que le
conflit israëlo-palestinien n'est pas
résolu et on pourra revenir si vous le
voulez sur ces différents paramètres qui
sont encore malheureusement en place oui
bien sûr on en parlera françoisbour oui
il faut pas trop charger les occidentaux
dans cette affaire ceux qui semblaient
avoir oublié le problème palestinien
c'était d'abord l'Autorité palestinienne
qui n'est plus que l'ombre d'elle-même
le ramas qui s'intéresse à la Palestine
comme d'une guigne c'est une
organisation islamiste
terroriste comparable dans ses actions à
daesh et à et à Al-Qaïda dans rénavant
ce n'était pas toujours le cas dans le
passé hein ça ça a
changé donc
Israël
et et et ses voisins palestiniens
redécouvre la question palestinienne qui
va diriger l'Autorité palestinienne à
l'avenir alors cette question là elle
est pas entre nos mains elle est entre
les mains à des responsables et des
populations locales donc ça c'est ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est à qui je disais qu'il a des
bénéficiaires il y a des perdants les
bénéficiaaires évident de cette guerre
et la crise qui s'ouvre dorénavant parce
que on a eu le choc et maintenant on
entre dans la on entre dans la grande
crise la la la les opérations terrestres
et la plus grosse crise d'otage que la
planète a jamais connue
j'étais en train de regarder le le
dernier des comptes et on a une
trentaine de pays qui ont des otages
actuellement à Gaza on n' jamais vu ça
beaucoup d'asiatiques beaucoup de
latino-américains et pas simplement des
Occidentaux pur sucre euh si je puis
dire alors ceux qui ceux qui ont
vraiment gagné à cette affaire ce sont
ceux qui étaient opposés effectivement
aux accords d'Abraham donc l'Iran euh
donc l'Arabie Saoudite est perdante euh
elle avait tenté h avec Israël de nouer
les relations je pense pas que ça puisse
vraiment se faire contenu des
circonstances actuelle l'Iran bien
entendu surf tout en ayant visiblement
très peur de d'éventuelles
répercussion à écouter l'ayatah ramene
avanthier
et voilà les les les les les vainqueurs
et les vaincus si je puis dire de cette
crise la Russie évidemment ne peut pas
être mécontente que l'on parle moins de
l'Ukraine mais à dire vrai ça ne change
pas grand-chose sur le terrain ça change
pas grand par contre il y a les
États-Unis et les États-Unis on ne sait
pas ce que ça va donner mais les
États-Unis reviennent au Moyen-Orient
bien sûr après 10 ans peut-être voilà
cont contint est forcé d'une certaine
façon cont forcé les Américains
reviennent et ça ça a les implications
en Europe et en et en Asie en Asie
Pacifique on va évidemment revenir sur
sur cette question notamment de de de
des États-Unis qui s'impliquent de
nouveau sur sur ce dossier au au Proche
Orient mais vous parliez de de l'Ukraine
euh je vous propose d'entendre parce que
ça fait plusieurs jours que volodimir
Zelenski fait le parallèle entre ce qui
se passe au au Proche Orient et en
Ukraine dernière en date c'était hier il
était au siège de l'OTAN à Bruxelles on
l'écoutetin les terroristes comme
Poutine ou comme le Hamas cherchent à
prendre en otage des nations libres et
démocratiques et ils veulent avoir le
pouvoir sur ceux qui cherchent la
liberté les terroristes ne changeront
pas ils doivent simplement
perdre C Berman c'est évidemment binaire
la question que je vais vous poser mais
est-ce le camp des démocraties qui se
défend contre celui des terroristes et
des dictateurs c'est souvent présenté de
cette manière mais comme comme vous le
dites c'est effectivement assez binaire
dans dans ce que disait Lenski bon on le
comprend aussi parce que d'abord il y a
une inquiétude de sa part parce que si
les Américains
euh doivent se réengager au Proche
Orient bon il craint qu'il le soit un
peu moins en Ukraine et ce terme de
terrorisme moi j'ai toujours eu un petit
peu des doutes c'est-à-dire que la
guerre de Poutine est une guerre
d'agression les crimes sont des crimes
de guerre il y a peut-être aussi des
crimes contre l'humanité mais moi
j'emploirai pas le terme de terrorisme
alors que en ce qui concerne le Hamas
c'est purement et simplement du du
terrorisme
effectivement il y a pas d'aut
qualification votre avis là-dessus
Damien Simono est-ce que alors je veux
pas qu'on reparte dans le débat qu'on a
eu dans notre première partie qui était
suffisamment houleux mais sur la
qualification du du du Hamas et
finalement dans dans quelle catégorie
doit-on doit-on les placer aujourd'hui
mais vous savez face à nos étudiants en
relations internationales on rappelle
qu'il faut dissocier la qualification
politique du terroriste comme la fait
zelensk ici en associant la Russie et et
le Hamas quelque part de l'analyse de
cette tactique qui est un mode d'action
par des des acteurs qui visent à tuer
des civils et qui visent à créer un
effet de sidération d'accord c'est
exactement ce qui nous a pris depuis
maintenant 5 jours ou quasiment plus et
chaque jour on découvre des choses donc
l'important c'est de voir qui le
qualifie et qui le disqualifie le Hamas
utilise le terrorisme ça fait partie de
sa tactique mais le Hamas est une entité
qui va au-delà du terrorisme c'est aussi
une organisationation même même après ce
qui s'est passé bien sûr c'est une
entité parce que ça ne les réduit pas à
ça finalement réduit à ça bien évid mais
c'est aussi une organisation politique
c'est aussi l'utilisation du terrorisme
ici s'inscrit dans une tacnique qui a
été avec des moyens plus conventionnels
entre guillemets que ce soit le fait de
bomber avec des drones par exemple les
différentes tours équipées autour du mur
de Gaza et cetera avec ce jeu de
rapprochement avec le hzbolla qui est
documenté maintenant depuis mai 2021 on
va bien qu'il y a un travail d'alliance
stratégique donc je pense que on peut
disqualifier le Hamas sur ces actions
terroristes là tout en analysant dans
quelle stratégie cela ie moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a cette opposition
démocrate et puis enfin ceux qui sont
pour la démocratie dictateur elle est un
peu binaire mais moi j'y vois autre
chose j'y vois des anciens des anciennes
grandes puissances qui sont racontés
cette histoire qu'elle resterait des
grandes puissances à décidé un petit peu
de ce qui se passe dans le monde à
décideré qu' aurait le nucléaire à
décideré quelle frontière serait dessiné
et qui ont cru que ça durerait
éternellement on voit bien que les
choses ne sont pas si évidentes que ça
qu'il y a des partis politiques en effet
qui émergent qui ont des pratiques
terroristes qui ont des façons de faire
euh de dictateurs qui ont des
organisations des régimes autoritaires
mais qui chamboule un peu ça et qui
chamboule les croyances que les
occidentaux ou les démocraties auraient
toujours raison et pourraient toujours
décider de la vie des uns et des autres
de la vie politique y compris et de
l'organisation des frontières je pense
qu'on est on n'est pas et on l'a vu
l'Union européenne par rapport à la
guerre en Ukraine on pèse beaucoup moins
on a dû revenir au- devant de la scène
rapatrier l'autant pour que elle est
qu'elle est à la foelle un nouveau rôle
parce que on était sur nos acquis en se
disant on va continuer avec cet ordre là
là c'est tout chamboulé et la
Chine là-dedans commence à émerger sur
un plan plus que économique jusqu'à
maintenant maintenant beaucoup plus
politique j'entends votre démonstration
min il y a quand même la question des
valeurs de la démocratie aussi parce que
est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas aussi
parce que je reviens à ma question un
peu binaire des deux camps mais c'est
quand même les valeurs de la démocratie
qui sont qui sont attaqué d'un côté quoi
quand vous avez 1200 personnes qui
viennent d'être égorgé abattu et cetera
comme des chiens vous n'êtes pas dans le
registre de la démocratie versus
l'antidémocratie vous êes vous êtes dans
quelque chose de très très différent oui
et je ne pense pas que ce soit le
paradigme qu'applique soit les
Israéliens soit la
ramass par rapport aux événements
actuels et je ne crois pas que mais en r
pardon inter c'est un peu le discours
qu'on entend
parfois chez Benjamin netaniaou
ou ou là dans le dans le discours de
zensk non non mais je non écoutez je
veux pas je veux pas servir la soupe à à
Benjamin netanahou qui finira
probablement sa carrière après avoir été
discracié par la commission d'enquête
qui se déroulera prochainement sur la
plus grosse faillite des instruments
d'État d'Israël depuis plus de 50 ans
euh
à je pense pas que ce soit une très
bonne source Zelenski c'est différent
Zelenski il joue bien sûr la survie de
son propre pays et il a joué euh en
dehors des qualific politique qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure he qui qui sont
ce qu'elles sont mais il a été
extrêmement habile euh soit parce qu'il
est bien pressenti qu'elle are qu'
allait être la réaction américaine soit
tout simplement parce que c'est un être
je pense raisonnablement moral mais il a
affiché vis-à-vis d'Israël dans cette
affaire une solidarité qu'Israël n'avait
pas du tout affiché vis-à-vis de
l'Ukraine lorsqu'elle a été agressé par
la Russie avec laquelle Poutine
entretient d'excellentes relations avec
Bibi nanahou hein je veux dire c'est là
non plus on nétait pas du côté israélien
et russe dans un débat entre la
démocratie et l'antidémocratie et donc
Zelenski a quelque part précédé euh la
l'immense décision par c'est une immense
décision américaine qui était revenir au
Moyen-Orient ils auraient pu les
Américains auraient pu se contenter de
dire c'est l'affaire des israélien ça
fait partie d'ailleurs du des décisions
annoncées par les américains ils ont dit
on fait confiance au israéliens euh pour
régler ça débrouillez-vous pour nous
pour nous récupérer nos aotages et ainsi
de suite non les Américains ont ajouté
on envoie un porte-avion et puis un
second et par ailleurs chers amis
iraniens chers amis du Hezbollah si vous
remuez le petit doigt il va vous en
cuire mais sérieusement grave si je si
je puis parler banlieu un instant
c'est et ça ce n'était pas ça n'allait
ça n'allait pas de soi euh en on
trouvera toujours des experts pour
expliquer après coup pourquoi c'était
inévitable mais en l'occurrence c'est
une décision
américaine qui se traduit par un par un
réalignement des priorités stratégiques
américaines pour moi c'est c'est la
conséquence géostratégique la plus
importante de cette affaire pour le
moment important alors je vais vous
donner la parole dans un instant mais je
propose à Tam tranui de de nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau parce que on on
va prolonger V votre analyse François
isbour en en se posant la question de
finalement des alliances qui qui
apparaissent dans ce conflit on commence
par Israël quels sont les pays qui se
tiennent au côté d'Israël aujourd'hui
c'est le cas de la majorité des pays
occidentaux ils ont condamné fermement
l'attaque terroriste de samedi dernier
d'abord on les voit sur cette carte en
bleu hein les États-Unis on en a parlé
allié historique d'Israël qui a commencé
l'envoi de ressources militaires on a
entendu le discours de solidarité sans
faille de Joe Biden et puis la dernière
image celle du jour qui illustre ce
soutien inconditionnel c'est celle de la
visite d'antthony blinken le chef de la
diplomatie américaine qui est donc
arrivé aujourd'hui à Tel Aviv autre
preuve le communiqué qui a été publié
lundi soir par la France l'Allemagne les
États-Unis l'Italie le Royaume-Uni ils
ont affirm ensemble qu'ils soutiennent
les efforts d'Israël pour se défendre
ils ont également indiqué que rien
jamais ne justifie le terrorisme noter
que la situation a forcé certains à
sortir de leur neutralité réputée comme
la Suisse qui ne considérait pas
jusqu'ici le Hamas comme une
organisation terroriste et dont le
gouvernement fédéral a annoncé vouloir
désormais changer de position c'était
hier sachez enfin que si la condamnation
est unanime du côté de l'Union
européenne on a toutefois vu émerger des
débats notamment sur les suites à donner
à cette attaque notamment au sujet de la
suspension ou non de l'aide européenne
aux Palestiniens et quels sont les pays
maintenant qui ont affiché leur soutien
au ramas ils ont salué l'offensive
soutenu officiellement l'organisation
terroriste c'est le cas par exemple de
l'Iran de de l'Algérie ou encore de la
Tunisie en rouge donc sur cette carte
l'Iran a été le premier pays à
s'exprimer dans ce Sensa dès dimanche le
président iranien Ibrahim Raisi a
déclaré l'Iran soutient la légitime
défense de la nation palestinienne et
appelle les autres gouvernement musulman
à faire de même en revanche le pays a
nié avoir aidé le Hamas à préparer cette
attaque l'Algérie est sur la même ligne
à souligné la légitimité de cette
attaque face à une je cite politique
d'oppression et de PER persécution
imposée au vaillant peuple palestinien
l'Algérie qui a dénoncé l'occupation
sioniste un terme aussi repris par la
Tunisie qui a dit son soutien total et
inconditionnel au peuple palestinien sur
la même ligne vous avez aussi des pays
géographiquement beaucoup plus éloignés
on les voit sur cette carte comme le
Venezuela ou encore la Malaisie et puis
dernière catégorie des pays qui ont une
position plus ambigu oui ce sont les
équilibristes ne condamnent pas
fermement le Hamas mais appelle au
cesser le feu c'est notamment le cas de
plusieurs pays de la Ligue arabe qui
avaient entamé un processus de
normalisation des relations avec Israël
vous avez le voisin égyptien aussi qui
s'est inquiété très tôt des conséquences
de l'escalade de violence et qui a
appelé un maximum de retenue même
position pour de pays du Golf que sont
les Émirats arabes unis ou encore le
Bahrain le Maroc lui a condamner les
attaques contre les civils d'où qu'ils
soi appelle à un arrêt immédiat de tous
les actes de violence même ligne pour
l'Arabie Saoudite la Turquie enfin la
Chine la Russie observe la situation de
près la Chine n'a pas non plus condamné
l'offensive du Hamas mais les actions
pourant portant atteinte à des civils
enfin la Russie n'a pas condamné mais
appelé un cesser le feu immédiat la
situation au Proche Orient fait
aujourd'hui il faut le dire les affaires
de Moscou qui espèrent ainsi un
détournement de latention internationale
de la guerre en Ukraine notamment celle
des Américains qui fournissent
aujourd'hui à eux seul la moitié de
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine merci
beaucoup Tam pour toutes ces
explications Sylvie Berman si on se
concentre effectivement sur les
États-Unis l'aide militaire des
Américains à l'Ukraine qui était déjà un
peu fragilisé on va dire par la la
campagne présidentielle et notamment
voilà les tensions a tour du vote du
budget il y a quelques jours je vais pas
raconter toute l'histoire est-ce que euh
ça accentue ce risque d'une certaine
façon d'un désengagement je mets des
guillemets américain de de l'Ukraine oui
bien sûr en tout cas c'est ce que craint
effectivement le l'Ukraine ça dépendra
éventu ça dépendra de de l'évolution des
des républicains cela dit les Américains
peuvent parfaitement faire les deux mais
il y a aux
États-Unis des communautés juives qui
font quand même pression sur le
gouvernement beaucoup plus que
finalement les communautés ukrainiennes
qui existent aussi d'ailleurs donc oui
il y a il y a un risque ça veut pas dire
que ça va se passer de cette manière
mais on peut pas dire que ça n'aura
aucune conséquence les États-Unis
voulaient se retir tiré d'Europe ils ont
été obligés de revenir en Europe avec la
guerre de Poutine les États-Unis
voulaient se retirer du Moyen-Orient à
cause de cette attaque terroristes du
Hamas ils reviennent effectivement au
Moyen-Orient ils vont retrouver un petit
peu entre guillemets leur rôle de
gendarmes du monde même si c'est souvent
alors françoisbour l'a dit tout à
l'heure hein ils ont envoyé
effectivement un porteavion ils ont
menacé ils fournissent également des des
armements mais même si finalement il
négocie plutôt indirectement avec le
Qatar avec l'Arabie Saoudite pour qu'il
puisse servir d'intermédiaire c'est sûr
que pour le moment avec l'Arabie
Saoudite bon le processus de
rapprochement avec Israël est sans doute
mort ça veut pas dire qu'il est mort
définitivement non plus Damien Simono la
proximité des États-Unis avec Israël
renforcé depuis depuis samedi est-ce
qu'elle les disqualifie dans un
processus de discussion ou une
négociation d'une certaine façon mais la
question c'est de savoir qui sont les
médiateurs possibles euh ça ça interroge
non seulement les États-Unis mais ça
interroge les Français et les Européens
là nous avons une situation en Israël et
dans les Territoires ptiniens où nous
avons face- à faceace un gouvernement de
droite et d'extrême droite dont certains
de ministres côté israélien prôent
justement la poursuite de la
colonisation et c'est peut-être une des
raisons justement du dégarnissement de
la de la frontière Gazaoui hein bon va
pas rentrer dans le débat stratégique
ici il y aura des leçons qui seront
tirées des commissions d'enquête plus
tard et en face on a le Hamas à Gaza
donc cuit de nos positionnements euh
j'entendais Dominique de Villepin ce
matin chez vos confrères de France
interre cuid des positionnements pour
renforcer les modérés dans les deux
camps on en est véritablement là en
Israël on se pose également la question
en fait de de de l'annexion de certaines
parties de la sis-jordanie de la
poursuite de la colonisation et en effet
qu'est-ce qu'on fait de Gaza maintenant
on a une opération militaire sans doute
terrestre qui va très certainement
terrestre qui va se mener et la question
qui doit interroger à mon avis nos
chancelleries ici en Europe qu'est-ce
que israël va faire de Gaza h quel euh
entité est-ce que l'on met lorsqu'on
aura décapité le Hamas soit dit est-ce
qu'on peut le décapiter puisqu'il est
décentralisé et que ses leaders sont
dans le golf ou ailleurs cela pose la
question des fondamentaux de ce conflit
qui est de dire Israël est selon le
droit international une puissance
occupante résolution 242 résolution 2334
du Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU Israël a
aussi une responsabilité dans les
partenaires qu'elle se choisit sur place
bien évidemment et Benyamin netaniao
actuellement en Israël est accusé
d'avoir laissé le Hamas se déployer
alors il y a plein de raisons là-dessus
mais il est aussi accusé de ça dans la
presse israélienne la question c'est ça
et nous en tant que Français qui prenons
la solution à deux états certes qui
sommes-nous prêts à appuyer dans les
sociétés israéliennes et palestiniennes
pour aboutir à cel françoisbour la
difficulté c'est que les voies modéré
elles se font moins entendre elles sont
un peu écrasé par les deux protagonistes
dans cette guerre il y a une guerre je
vous rappelle que Israël a déclaré la
guerre au Hamas et visiblement c'est
réciproque autrement dit la voix n'est
vraiment pas à la modération
et ça c'est la première observation la
deuxième observation c'est que cette
guerre ne fait que commencer et
autrement dit ce qui va occuper la scène
médiatique et politique dans les
semaines qui viennent ça va être deux
choses ce sont les opérations
israéliennes à Gaza et notamment
l'opération terrestre qui sera
extrêmement dure extrêmement
brutal d'une part et la crise des otages
j'allis revenir sort des hôel parce que
ça je je reprends l'expression pardon
même si vous de de d'une guerre
mondialisée ça internationalise ce qui
se passe oui mais c'est pas bon c'est
pas c'est encore une fois on va pas
parler je dire c'est tout ça est
suffisamment inquiétant pour qu'on dise
pas dans les chaumières ah oui c'est la
guerre mondiale
pasiis d'ord mais on passe rapidement de
l'un l'autre oui bon
l'internationalisation elle passe
effectivement par le sort des otages
aussi et le sort des otages euh
la plus je crois que vous êtes tous plus
jeunes que moi j'ai le souvenir
personnel quand même de l'impact de la
prise d'otage de l'ambassade américaine
en
Iran après l'arrivée au pouvoir des Mola
et qui a complètement écrasé la vie
politique américaine pendant 444 jours
et et les médias tous les jours vous
aviez 441e jour 4 et en France même
tabac lors des prises d'otage euh de
journalistes et de chercheurs au Liban
euh dans la 2e moitié des années 80 au
point où ça a pu influencer le cours
d'au moins une élection présidentielle
en France euh euh là ça va être à la
puissance 2 ou à LA PUISSANCE 3 et
l'heure euh des comment euh ne va
vraiment pas être à l'analyse de l'art
et de la manière dont on va pouvoir
traiter au fond comme on doit le faire
éventuellement il va falloir traiter au
fond la question palestinienne mais pour
ça un il faudra que la situation à Gaza
ne permettre plus au Hamas de monter le
type d'opération qu' qu'il a monté avec
beaucoup d'efficacité d'horreur l'autre
jour et pour les Israéliens ça veut dire
déracinement de l'infrastructure du
Hamas à Gaza et ça c'est pas du tout
dispersé c'est pas du tout diasporisé ça
c'est intensément local de deuxièement
il faudra qu'Israël résolve ses
problèmes de politique intérieure et ça
je pense que ça se fera relativement
vite parce que Benjamin netanahou sera
évidemment
chargé de tous les péchés puisque c'est
sous son égy que tout ça se déroule et
c'est pas le résultat n'est pas brillant
et troisièmement il va falloir qu'il y
ait un responsable de l'Autorité
palestinienne qui dont on a des preuves
réelles qu'il qu'il est encore vivant
bon je sais bien qu'amazen n'est pas
mort mort mais on ne peut pas vraiment
dire qu'il soit très vivant non plus euh
ces trois conditionslà elles ne vont pas
être remplies dans les semaines qui
viennent euh autrement dit les
discussions que l'on peut avoir sur un
futur ordre sur un futur règlement au
MoyenOrient sont des discussions qui
sont extrêmement importantes sur le fond
mais prématur mais mais très prématuré
en ce qui concerne la captation de
l'attention des responsables
politiquesou je je je je reviens à
l'engagement américain syv Berman on se
souvient tous d'une époque où les
présidents américains se rêvaient les
uns après les autres en faiseurs de
paix'est qu' a comment comment ça
comment ça s'est déliter à ce point ben
je pense que peu à peu il y a eu
effectivement un désintérêt et puis
surtout un desésintérêts des pays arabes
qui étaient prêt enfin des dirigeants
arabes qui étaient prêts à avoir des des
relations avec Israël et c'est le choix
qu'on fait les Américains et chacun des
accords je sais plus combien il y en a
eu il y a eu plusieurs cand David il y a
eu charmelcher il y a eu tabac enfin bon
et à chaque fois sans parler des accords
d'osloot bien sûr ça a été un un échec
et
donc voilà il y a eu un peu de
découragement moi j'ai passé enfin j'ai
plus de 40 ans de de vie diplomatique
chaque réunion européenne on faisait une
déclaration sur ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque le processus de paix on
nemployait même plus le terme de crise
israëlpalestinienne conflit ou autre ça
s'appelait processus de paix au
Moyen-Orient alors que il était moribon
depuis longtemps et puis bah le temps a
passé et effectivement il y a eu
d'autres principes qui ont été appliqué
celui du réalisme celui de l'économie et
qui devait conduire à la normalisation
avec l'Arabie Saoudite qui était
véritablement en cours oui moi je vous
rejoins tout à fait ce que disait
notamment dans votre reportage
introductif ce que dit Agnès leevallois
quelque part l'Arabie saoudite a essayé
dans le cadre de sa normalisation avec
Israël justement de un peu ramener la
question palestinienne et a essayé
quelque part d'OB je dis peut-être pas
d'obtenir des concessions mais du moins
de mettre ça sur la table donc là on
avait un médiateur qui était un peu dans
la droite ligne de ce qu'il avait
proposé en 2002 l'initiative de paix
arabe derrière plusieurs pays
arabomusulmans qui demandait une
reconnaissance d'Israël en échange de la
constitution d'un État palestinien dans
les frontières de 67 je voulais juste
réagir sur les États-Unis gendarmes du
monde je ne suis pas vraiment sûr que
les Américains et notamment à l' proche
des élections 2024 ont vraiment envie
d'aller dans ce sens-là he les citoyens
américains je veux dire et ensuite votre
carte du grand continent qui est tout à
fait parlante si on fait une carte
similaire sur le soutien à l'Ukraine
vis-à-vis de l'agression russe on a
aussi une carte assez similaire
c'est-à-dire qu'on a quand même beaucoup
d'États dans le monde qui sont disons on
va dire sceptiques critiques des
positionnements occidentaux et qui
notamment mettre en avant le décalage
entre les principes les normes notamment
de loi et les soutiens et la mise en
œuvre de processus de médiation ou ou de
changement ou de sanction ça ça doit à
mon avis aussi quand même nous
interroger François oui c'est la
géopolitique de la crise et vous avez
tout à fait raison de la de la soulever
je noterai quand même quelques
différences très importantes l'Inde est
clairement dans le camp occidental dans
cette affaire l'Argentine aussi si on
prend les pays du G20 on est dans
quelque chose où je pense qu'une
majorité des pays du G20 qui comprend
pas simplement les pays occidentaux et
on est dans quelque chose d'assez
différent de l'Ukraine la Chine qui a
perdu quatre de ses ressortissants euh
parce qu'il y a quatre chinois qui ont
été tués par les mecs du ramas thaande
également comment la Thaïlande également
ah oui al la Thaïlande n'en parlons pas
ils ils ont eu 21 morts euh et ils ont
encore une quinzaines de de
disparus la Thaïlande considère que les
16 disparus c'est 16 euh sont entre les
mains euh du euh du ramas euh ça ça ne
dessine pas une géopolitique comparable
à celle j'allais dire de la lutte des
grands États euh que l'on voit dans
l'affaire dans l'affaire
russoukrainienne là on est dans on est
dans quelque chose de plus diffus de
plus fragmenté euh c'est pas la Guer
c'est pas la la la guerre mondialisée
c'est le monde fragmenté c'est euh c'est
comme ça que je vois sur les États-Unis
euh moi j'ai pas employé l'expression
gendarme monde je considère
qu'effectivement c'est pas la ce n'est
pas de ça dont il s'agit il s'agit de
savoir si les États-Unis considèrent
qu'ils peuvent
euh se se mettre en en 3è rideau faire
comme le disait l'entourage de d'Obama
il y a une douzaine d'années il voulait
faire du leading from behind la la
conduite depuis la banquette arrière euh
ben comme chacun sait la conduite depuis
la banquette arrière c'est pas un truc
génial ni pour le conducteur
c'est pas une bonne formule en relation
internation sur le fait de savoir si les
États-Unis vont aider à la fois
l'Ukraine et Israël le ce qui la
discussion qui a lieu en ce moment à
Washington c'est de voir si on peut pas
jumeler la résolution de l'aide à Israël
avec la résolution sur l'aide à
l'Ukraine faire voter ça en même temps
faire voter ça de façon conjointe de
traiter ça comme un ensemble je ne sais
pas si ça passera ce sera un test ce
sera un test très important par rapport
à tout ce qui a été dit sur la question
de savoir si l'Ukraine continuera ou non
à bénéficier du même soutien que dans le
passé alors on parlait de vous parliez
d'évoquer le G20 les questions de
gouvernance mondiale Émilie il y a il y
a il y a encore une fois un constat
d'impuissance de l'ONU depuis depuis bah
oui c'est ce qu'on voit au fil des
conflit Ukraine Israël la question de
l'efficacité voire même de l'utilité de
l'ONU se pose ce machin comme disait
char de GA depuis sa création son bilan
est assez mitigé et notamment sa
capacité à mettre fin aux violences aux
conflits dans le monde syriie Yémen
exyoslavie Irak alors le bilan de ces
entités spécialisées est plus flatteur
si on parle notamment de l'UNICEF pour
l'enfance du Programme alimentaire
mondial sans compter aussi l'aide au
développement que l'ONU permet
d'acheminer pour les pays qui sont
touchés par des conflits ça le bilan est
plutôt bon mais actuellement s'agissant
là du conflit au Proche Orient l'ONU
multiplie les déclarations sans sembl
marquer son but on écoute justement son
secrétaire général qui appelle à des
résolutions c'était
hier je suis en contact permanent avec
les dirigeants de la région avec un
regard immédiat sur plusieurs priorités
essentielles nous devons éviter un
débordement du
conflit je suis préoccupé par
l'intensification récente des tirs le
long de la ligne bleue et par les
récentes attaques signalées en
provenance du sud
Liban j'en appelle à toutes les parties
et influence sur ces parties pour éviter
toute nouvelle escalade et tout
débordement c'est plus de l'ordre de
l'incantation et on a vu aussi dans le
cadre de la guerre en Ukraine l'ONU qui
faisait plutôt office de figurant et ça
a évidemment un rapport avec la
composition de son Conseil de sécurité
oui le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU il
se compose de 15 membres et il y en a
cinq qui sont permanents les États-Unis
la Chine la Russie la France et le
Royaume-Uni chacun a des intérêts
différent mais chacun a un droit de véau
et donc ce droit de vetau qu'il possède
rend évidemment très difficile les
positions communes c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui a amené le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensk à demander la réforme
du Conseil de sécurité lors d'un
discours qu'il a prononcé en personne à
New York en en septembre dernier sa
proposition c'était de supprimer le
droit de vetto évidemment en
l'occurrence de la Russie et d'élargir
la composition du Conseil de sécurité
notamment pour intégrer par exemple les
pays d'Afrique ou d'Asie une façon
finalement d'adapter l'ONU au nouveau
rapport de force mondiaux cette réforme
a-t-elle une chance d'aboutir alors il y
a peu de temp encore certains on se
souvient d'Emmanuel Macron voyent l'UTAN
l'organisation de du Traité de
l'Atlantique Nord en état de mort
cérébrale finalement on peut dire que
l'Olan c'est en quelque sorte réveillé
avec le conflit ukrainien il faut voir
si l'invasion ukrainienne et ce nouveau
conflit au proch Orient pourrait aussi
servir d'électrochoc pour l'ONU merci
Émilie syv Berman à quoi sert l'ONU
est-ce que ça sert encore à quelque
chose c'est souvent plus une tribune
qu'autre chose la dernière fois qu'il y
a eu une RA rolution du Conseil de
sécurité importante sur le Moyen-Orient
c'était en 2006 et au moment de la
guerre en Liban et pour pratiquement la
dernière fois d'ailleurs le Conseil de
sécurité a été en mesure de conclure un
cesser le feu et de mettre également en
place la finule renforcée pour le reste
effectivement d'ailleurs le le
secrétaire général le disait hein il a 5
m et il ne peut rien faire s'il n'a pas
la acccord de ces 5 m faut pas oublier
non plus euh la la guerre en Irak qui
s'est faite contre euh le Conseil de
sécurité et de manière générale les
Américains n'acceptaient jamais une
résolution sur le Moyen-Orient ou sur la
décolonisation il y a longtemps que ce
sujet avait été écarté des des débats au
Conseil de sécurité bon aujourd'hui
évidemment dans la mesure où euh la
Russie est un pays agresseur ça
complique les choses la réforme elle est
discutée depuis plus de 20 ans moi
j'étais encore directrice des Nations
Unies organisation internationale il y
avait un groupe dit le G4 avec le Brésil
l'Inde euh le Japon l'Allemagne plus des
pays euh africains mais il y a jamais eu
d'accord des voisins à ce moment-là
toutes les puissances sauf le
Royaume-Uni et la et la France qui était
favorable à une réforme du droit de véto
et un élargissement était très méfiant
aujourd'hui ça peut changer parce que la
ch Chine et la Russie peuvent avoir
intérêt à voir entré le Brésil l'Inde
parce que ça modifierait aussi
l'équilibre du Conseil de sécurité
récemment Joe Biden a proposé aussi une
réforme mais quel serait le le cadre de
cette réforme mais il faudra là aussi
après c'est du très long
terme voir comment on peut réformer la
gouvernance mondiale ce n'est pas
tenable d'avoir les vainqueurs de 19 45
qui prétendent diriger le monde François
isbourg je voudrais qu'on termine juste
pour on a évoqué un tout petit peu la
Chine mais est-ce que ce qui ce ce cette
résurgence du conflit au au proch Orient
c'est une opportunité pour la Chine
alors deux choses tout d'abord la Chine
n'admettra et le fait savoir très
clairement c'était vrai du temps où vous
y étiez et c'est encore plus vrai
aujourd'hui il n pas question pour elle
de laisser entrer l'Inde qui est
aujourd'hui en polarité stratégique
opposé par rapport à la à la Chine
deuxièmement tout le monde paraît
heureux quand on évoque la la
possibilité d'une médiation chinoise au
Moyen-Orient euh une façon de refiler le
mistigriis que les Occidentaux
visiblement n'arrivent effectivement pas
à gérer
euh welcome welcome to the club grosso
modo dit-on au chinois euh mais les
Chinois font en l'occurrence euh très
attention euh parce que je crois qu'ils
savent que la région est un est un baril
de poudre et que manier de la poudre
tous les jours ça peut comporter des
conséquences
désagréables surtout si
d'autres
prétend vouloir s'en s'en occuper on ne
voit on ne voit pas la Chine aujourd'hui
malgré son statut de quasi super
puissance euh on ne la voit pas prendre
des positions aussi forte au plan
stratégique au Moyen-Orient que ne le
fait la Russie avec son pb qui est
voisin de celui de l'Italie euh et dans
les moyens militaires au Moyen-Orient
euh sont euh comment dire limités ouis
je voulais juste rajouter quelque chose
quand même sur pour répondre à vre
question à quoi sert l'ONU la justice
internationale hein euh il faut le
rappeler bien évidemment on a parlé tout
à l'heure de des massacres du Hamas euh
la Cour pénale internationale est aussi
là pour qualifier et pour mener des
enquêtes sur euh des crimes de guerre
des crimes contre l'humanité il y a
quand même tout un registre général et
c'est important de le dire mais force de
constater que notamment on l'a vu
également en Ukraine qu'on assiste
plutôt à une période d'érosion de ces
normes-l beaucoup d'États justement ont
tendance à jouer avec ces normes
internationales que ce soit dans le
domaine de la guerre que soit dans le
domaine de l'immigration soit dans le
même du statut des réfugiés et là c'est
quand même très très inquiétant et je
crois que quand on voit ce ce conflit
israell Hamas c'est ça qui nous saisit
quelque part c'est un peu l'impuissance
à faire vivre ces normes mais à sentir
qu'elle s'de parce qu'on est dominé par
la guerre qui est dans dans l'immédiat
ce qui nous concerne ces jour-ci et on a
bien compris que c'était l'horizon à
moyen terme merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vais rappeler le
titre de vos livres Sylvie Berman madame
l'ambassadeur qui est publié aux
éditions Talandier françoisbourg les
leçons d'une guerre guerre en Ukraine
évidemment publié aux éditions ODIL
Jacob noté que demain l'invité de la
matinale de Public Sénat sera Stéphan
Simon producteur de télévision auteur de
ce livre les derniers jours de Samuel
Patti enquête sur une tragédie qui
aurait dû être évitée je vous remercie à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité merci
Émilie à très bientôt bonne soirée à
tous